in the
Harvest feels now
ripened there's a
work for all to do
AR the
voice of God is
calling to the
Harvest calling
you little is
much when God is in
it labor
not for wealth or
fame there's a crown
and you can win
it if you
go in Jesus
name little is
much when God is in
it labor
not for wealth for
fame there's a crown
and you can win
it if you
go in Jesus
name that's the
place you're called to
labor seem so
small yet little
known it is great
if God is in
it and he'll
not forget his
own little is
much when God is in
it labor
not for wealth or
fame there is a
crown and you can win
it if you
go in Jesus
name little is
much when God is in
it labor
not for wealth or
fame there's a
crown and you can win
it if you
go in Jesus
name when the
con flict here has
ended and all
race on Earth is
run he will
say if we've been
faithful welcome
home my child will
done little is
much when God is in
it labor
not for wealth or
fame there's a
crown and you can win
it if you
go in Jesus
name little is
much when God is in
it labor
not for wealth or
Fai there is a
crown and you can win
it if you
go in Jesus
name little is
much when God is in
it they burn
not forth our
F there is a
crown in you can win
it if you
go in
Jesus name
[Music]
sanctify them through thy
truth Thy word is
truth I am the way the truth and the
life no man cometh unto the father but
by
me the spirit is truth I've given three
verses John
1717 John
14:6 1 John
56 I could have added Deuteronomy 32:4
which says God is a god of Truth I've
done that for this
reason I will not preach a sermon this
evening I will try to answer some
questions that were sent on the internet
I feel led by God to do this so our
title is questions and
answers every night I ask you to pray
for me that the Lord will put his words
in my mouth I'm not quite sure I'm not
sure at all to what degree you accept
this request as serious but I'm asking
you tonight wherever you are ask God to
put his words in my mouth as I try to
explain some issues brought to my
attention by those who listen and God
bless them wherever they are so I will
be answering some questions I'm sure it
will take up all the time I did have a
message prepared
but when my good brother sent me a
couple of questions I felt convicted to
deal with that instead of adding a layer
of knowledge you see if your foundation
is not secure whatever you put on top of
it will collapse and so that's why I've
decided to entitle this presentation
questions and answers and I believe you
will be blessed as the Holy Spirit leads
me in answering these questions
before I go any further remember always
now this time this is on because I have
to read the question that was sent so
mine is on but the volume is down so if
you're using a phone please make sure it
does not ring in the presence of God
favor number two here it comes while I'm
speaking pray for me and say Lord put
your words in that man's
mouth I need that help because I'm human
I'm flesh I am dirt I am clay I am all
of these things combined and multiplied
and so I need the Fulfillment of the
words of Christ in John
16:13 how be it when he the spirit of
Truth has come he will guide you into
all truth and I need that right now so
ask God to put his words in my mouth my
text for that Jeremiah
1:9 then the Lord put forth his hand and
tou touch my mouth and the Lord said
unto me behold I have put my words in
thy mouth and as always favor number
three think Isaiah 1:18 come now let us
reason together and as I go through this
presentation you will see the necessity
of reasoning it is essential to reason
when studying the Bible because the
Bible is not a book mainly of proof it
is a book of evidence
where there is proof you don't need
Faith where there is evidence you need
Faith to follow in the direction in
which the evidence points this even goes
on in secular courtrooms cases are
decided on the basis of evidence seldom
absolute proof when we reason honestly
the spirit of God will guide our minds
in the path of truth let's
pray Father in Heaven thank you so much
much for the gift of
life thank you de God for the precious
promises in your word one of those
promises you made to Moses but I need
them Moses doesn't need that now Exodus
4:12 you said to him now therefore go
and I will be with thy mouth and teach
thee what Thou shalt say fulfill that
promise for me de God as I humble myself
before you my desire is to present thus
sayth the Lord grant me your spirit de
God to enable me to do this to a degree
that glorifies your name and clarifies
the issues for those who desire truth I
ask you to bless everyone listening to
God I always pray for all the countries
represented by this audience wherever
they are however far flung your mercy
and your grace can reach them touch each
person individually I ask you to pour
out a special blessing on the visitors
there God those who were not seventh
Adventists bless them in a very signal
way and a special double blessing on
their children bless the leaders of the
countries dear God this covid-19 has
created catastrophe in certain countries
more than in others pour out your mercy
according their God to the condition in
which people find themselves because
you're are God of Mercy now father I lay
myself in your hands use me as a
mouthpiece for the truth truth I pray
from my heart in Jesus name
amen the questions arose from last
night's presentation where I was perhaps
fairly forceful and calling upon people
who keep Sunday to stop if they do IGN
knowingly willfully deliberately
intentionally flagrantly keeping a day
that God did not sanctify and I believe
it was that that led to the question let
me turn to question
one and uh
read it as best I understand it let me
get out two extra
eyes and read thist here's what the
person
said in his own
words Jesus made it
clear that the laws of Moses and of the
Prophet were valid until the time of
John the
Baptist now we'll go to Luke 16 16 the
person said Jesus in his own words made
it
clear that the laws of Moses and the
prophets were valid up to John the
Baptist meaning they ceased to have any
validity at John they stopped they were
useless they were not they were
obsolete is this what Jesus is saying
let us go to Luke 16 verse 16 our
subject questions and answers Luke 16
reading verse
16 listen to the question again
Jesus no it says in his own words and
the person is referring to Luke
16:16 Jesus made it
clear that the laws of Moses and of the
prophets were valid until the time time
of John the Baptist meaning they lost
validity and meaning they became
obsolete with the beginning of the
ministry of John the Baptist all right
here is what Luke
says the law and the prophets were until
John the Baptist since that time the
kingdom of God is preached and every man
presses into it listen again the
law and the prophets were until John the
Baptist the writer of the question is
taking that expression to mean that the
law and the prophets ended at John the
Baptist I checked
26 Bible
versions not one of them says that
because that's not what the text is
saying the law and the prophets were
until John the Baptist since that time
since John the Baptist began his
ministry the kingdom of God is preached
and every man presseth into it go to
Matthew 3 Let's see what presseth into
it means Matthew 3 we'll read from verse
5 this is about John the Baptist and his
ministry Matthew
3:5 then went out to him Jerusalem and
all Judea and all the region round about
Jordan and were baptized of him in
Jordan confessing their sins but when he
saw many of the Pharisees and Sadducees
come to his baptism he said unto them oh
Generation of Vipers who have warned you
to flee from the Wrath to come they were
coming to John in droves because the
message John was preaching they had
never
heard and so when Jesus says in John in
Luke 16:16 and every man presseth into
it there were coming the Bible says all
of Jerusalem and all of Judea and all
the region roundout Jordan came to John
and were baptized of him in Jordan
confessing their sins there was a
preaching of repentance the kingdom of
God is at hand which is what John was
preaching which is what Jesus preached
because John prepared the way for Jesus
so when Jesus says since that time Luke
16:16 the kingdom of God is preached in
was from the preaching of John people
have been coming to be baptized they've
heard of this new doctrine it wasn't new
it was just that the Jews misinterpreted
the Old
Testament let me
explain by asking you this question and
those of you listening when Christ was
born did the Jewish Nation know he had
come yes or no no now was Christ
prophesied all through the Old Testament
yes
they didn't know because the law and the
prophets and the Psalms which is a word
for the writings talked about
Jesus but because they study the
scriptures looking for an Earthly
Messiah the mindset you bring to the
Bible is essential to understand what
the Bible is saying they were looking
for someone who would deliver them from
successive oppression first the
Babylonians well even before the
Babylonians the syrians had conquered
the northern kingdom in 721 722 BC the
southern Kingdom fell in about 586 so we
have the Assyrians we have the
Babylonians we have the m and the
Persians we have the Greeks then we have
the Romans and all these Powers over the
Jews they are looking for someone who is
an Earthly
deliverer when Jesus came as a deliverer
from sin they didn't know because they
misunderstood the Bible because they
brought to it the wrong mindset now the
only people who knew were three wise men
from hundreds of miles away because they
studied correctly and the Shepherds who
were told after Jesus was born I say
again an entire nation studying the law
and the prophets but studying badly did
not know so Jesus says the law and the
prophets were until John this was your
source of information this is is what
was proclaimed to you this is what you
relied on for your knowledge of God but
now the kingdom of God is preached by
this same
John another point to bear in
mind the writer of the question said
Jesus in his own words declared the laws
of Moses and the prophets to be extinct
and no longer valid the Bible does not
say the laws it just says the law and
that's significant you read any Bible
version of Luke 16:16 it does not say
the laws and the prophet were until John
the Baptist it says the
law now why is that
significant in the Bible the expression
the law and the prophets or the law of
Moses and the prophets refer to
different sections of the Old Testament
let me explain let me pray first father
be with me restrain my human nature let
only your spirit have his way in Jesus
name I pray amen before I explained the
law and the prophets and the LA Moses
let's read verse 16 again in the light
of what the person wrote and I must read
what the person wrote again listen I
must read it I need to be fair the
person says in his own words referring
to Luke 16:16 Jesus made it clear that
the laws of Moses and of the prophets
were valid until the time of John the
Baptist which mean they cease to be
valid with the coming of John the
Baptist now listen to 16 then we'll go
to
17 the law and the prophets were until
John since that time the kingdom of God
is preached and every man presseth into
it listen to verse 17 listen
carefully and it is easier for heaven
and earth to
pass than for one title of the law to
fail the same law the person says was
made invalid in verse
16 Jesus says in verse 17 Heaven and
Earth will pass before one title of the
law passes now how do you explain
that because you cannot build a theology
on one verse are you following me listen
again the person said Jesus made it
clear that the law and the prophets were
invalid when John came Jesus said in
verse 17 and it is easier for heaven and
earth to pass which means as long as
there's a heaven and there's an earth
the law of God is valid somebody say
Amen now I was talking about the law the
law of Moses the law and the
prophets sometimes the Bible says the
law of
Moses sometimes it just says the law
sometimes it just says Moses let's go to
Luke 24 let me show you what I mean we
will reason from scripture to scripture
and let me remind you please pray for me
and ask God to put his words in my mouth
I believe there people listening all
over the world and I want to make sure
they minds are guided into the path of
Truth what book did I
say what book did I
say what chapter 24 what verse
27 Luke 242 let me set it up you know
the story of Christ talking to the the
two disciples on the road to EMAs Christ
had risen from the dead the disciples
did not believe it these two disciples
are walking and they're depressed Jesus
Jesus appears to them what are you
talking about and they tell him in verse
21 but we had trusted that it had been
him we should have redeemed Israel and
beside all this this is now the third
day since all this began all this
happened they're just telling this sad
story and uh we're depressed he did not
deliver Israel they have the same
mindset as the Old Testament people who
did not believe that Christ was coming
they did not study the Bible properly
now Jesus said to them in verse 25 oh
fools and slow of heart to believe all
that the prophets have
spoken was not Christ to suffer these
things and to enter into his glory what
do you mean by suffer these things the
crucifixion the point of the discussion
is the crucifiction and the resurrection
let me say that again particularly the
resurrection did did not believe he had
risen the point under discussion Christ
is trying to clarify is that the Bible
said I will rise and so Jesus says ought
not Christ to have suffered these things
and to enter into his glory he could not
enter the glory if he had stayed dead
verse 27 and beginning at
Moses and all the prophets he expounded
unto them in all the scriptures which is
the Old Testament the things concerning
himself listen again and beginning at
Moses and all the prophets he expounded
unto them in all the scriptures so all
the scriptures must include all the
writings of
Moses even though just the word Moses is
used now let's go to verse 44 of that
same chapter it is the same discussion
but this time to more of the disciples
not just the
two Luke
24:44 and he said unto them these are
the words which I spake unto you while I
was yet with you that all things should
be fulfilled which were written in what
the law of Moses and the prophets and
the psalms now in verse 27 he began
where at Moses in verse 44 it says the
law of Moses it's the same thing he
simply said Moses because the Jews
understood when he said Moses he meant
the writings of Moses now in verse 44 he
says the law of Moses the prophets and
the Psalms the Old Testament as I said
earlier was divided into the law of
Moses Genesis to
Deuteronomy then the prophets Joshua to
Malachi and within that group you had
historical prophets you had the earlier
prophets and the latter prophets then
the Psalms was used to refer to the the
the holy
writings job Psalm Proverbs Ecclesiastes
sounds of Solomon Ruth Esther
Lamentations they were all the holy
writings but the most popular was the
Psalms and so the word Psalms is used
just to identify all the holy writings
Jesus the law of Moses the prophets the
Psalms or the holy writings in verse 27
he just says Moses in verse 44 he says
the law of Moses so sometimes the law of
Moses can be referred to Simply as Moses
or simply the law as in the case of Luke
16:16 the law and the prophets which
should be the law of Moses and the
prophets were until John the Baptist now
let's take a look at the law of Moses
and see what the Bible
means let me slow down a little give you
time to digest what you're hearing we're
looking at the law of Moses let's reason
together let us go to 1 Corinthians
9:9 1 Corinthians 9:9 now let me go back
to the person's question the person is
assuming that the word law in Luke 16:16
refers to the Ten Commandments because I
was preaching on the Sabbath and I was
fairly forceful you ought to keep the
Sabbath clearly this person is saying
the law of God the Ten Commandments
ceased with John the Baptist all right
we are now at 1 Corinthians 9 verse
99 the Bible says for it is written in
the law of Moses what you tell
me Thou shalt not muzzle the ox that
treadeth out the
corn read microscopically look at how
the verse Begins for it is written in
the law of Moses now if the law of Moses
refers to the Ten Commandments you tell
me which of the Ten Commandments say
thou shalt not muszle the ox that
treadeth out the corn which one not one
clearly this expression the law of Moses
refers to the five books because the the
same saying Thou shalt not Mule the ox
that treadeth out the corn is found in
Deuteronomy
24:5 Deuteronomy 24:5 Thou shalt not
muscle the ox when he treadeth out the
corn Paul says it is written in the law
of Moses then Deuteronomy must be a part
of the law of
Moses ah did I lose
you repetition is an effective tool of
teaching let me
repeat let me pray again father please
God don't leave me in the Pulpit
struggling speak through me literally
their father I humble myself before you
literally speak through me as I deal
with this most important subject because
it was the violation of the Lord that
led to the death of your son hear me
father in Jesus name
amen well let's try another example go
to John 8 let's go to John 8 it's 20
after 7 John 8 we're looking at the law
of Moses does that term refer to the Ten
Commandments and we have to reason
honestly you have John
8 in the story in this chapter we have
the story of the woman taken in
adultery verse four says and when they
set in the midst they said unto him
Master this woman was taken in adultery
in in adultery in the very act now Moses
in the law commanded that such should be
stoned but what sayest thou now listen
again Moses in the
law commanded that such should be Stone
now if the law refers to the Ten
Commandments you tell me which of the
Ten Commandments contains the punishment
for
adultery none of
them but John the closest disciple to
Jesus Christ he says he reports Moses in
the law wrote or said that such should
be stoned you know where that's found
Leviticus 20:10 Deuteronomy 22: 21- 24
which means Leviticus is part of the law
of
Moses do we have
Deuteronomy we have Leviticus they are
both part of the law of Moses because
the law of Moses does the Ten
Commandments do not express the
punishment for adultery the ten command
Commandments do not state that thou
shalt not muzzle the ox that tread out
the corn yet the Bible says the law of
Moses said these
things let's go back to Luke 24 where
the resurrection of Jesus Christ is the
issue under discussion the disciples did
not believe it and Christ is trying to
show them that the entire Old Testament
predicted these things now listen to
verse 44 and he said unto them these are
the words Words which I spake unto you
while I was yet with you that all things
must be fulfilled that are written in
the law of Moses and the prophets and
the Psalms concerning me meaning his
resurrection but where in the Ten
Commandments is the resurrection of
Jesus
mentioned so the law of Moses cannot be
the Ten Commandments because the Ten
Commandments do not speak about the
resurrection of Jesus Christ what I'm
trying to tell you when you see the law
of Moses you cannot automatically assume
the Bible is referring to the Ten
Commandments you've got to study the
context of that
passage and we've seen 1 Corinthians 9:9
for it is written in the law of Moses
Thou shalt not musle the ox that tread
out the corn that's found in Deuteronomy
24:5 that's the law of Moses
now let's go to uh
John 5 John 5 we're trying to answer
questions John 5 and I'm taking a lot of
time on this because the issue with
people is the law of God the law of
God and there's a reason for that but
it's not a pleasant reason but it's
biblical and I may have to tell you John
5 I know you that he uh verse 42 but I
know you that you have not the love of
God in you I am come in my own name and
you receive me not if another shall come
in his name him you will receive
how can you believe which receive honor
one of another and seek not the honor
that Cometh From God only do not think
that I will accuse you to the father
there is another who accuses you even
Moses in whom you trust what does he
mean by Moses will accuse them Moses
does not accuse people Christ is
referring to the writings of
Moses for had you believed Moses you
would have believed me for he wrote of
me last verse I think it's vers 47 but
if he believe not his what come on if he
believe not his what his writings how
can you believe my words now let's look
at the writings of Moses by looking at
the writings of God go to uh not
Deuteronomy Exodus 32 we'll read verse
15 and verse 16 our subject questions
and answers Deuteronomy
325 and 16
and may the good god of Heaven put his
words in my mouth I want everybody saved
no one can be saved in Disobedience
absolutely
not and Moses turned and went down from
the mount and the two tables of
testimony were in his hand the tables
were written on both their sides on the
one side and on the other side were they
written and the tables verse 16 were
what the work of God keep reading and
the writing come on was the writing of
God the Ten Commandments were not
written by
Moses they were written by God
twice so when Jesus said in verse 47 of
John 5 but if you believe not his
writings how shall you believe my words
it is not the Ten Commandments it's a
reference to the first five books of the
Bible which are called The Books of
Moses because he wrote
them the writings of of Moses do not
include the Ten Commandments they are
within his writings but they were
written by
God Moses might have copied them but
they originally written by god let's go
to Exodus 31 let's read Verse 18 as we
identify the writings of Moses by
identifying the writings of God Exodus
31: 18 our subject questions and
answers book number 2 of
Exodus verse chapter 31 verse
18 and he gave unto Moses when he had
made an end of communing with him upon
Mount Si two tables of testimony tables
of stone you finish the verse written
with the Finger of God the Ten
Commandments were not written by Moses
they were written by God and so the
writings of Moses cannot strictly
include the Ten Commandments even though
they're found within the first five
books they were written by
God when the Bible talks about if he
believe not his writings how shall he
believe my words Christ is referring to
the first five books of the
Bible let's go back to Luke
16 verse 16 and let me reread the
person's question
and I hope many of my friends online
have told God put your words in that
man's mouth listen
again in his own words this is very
emphatic Jesus made it
clear that the laws of Moses and the
Bible doesn't say the laws of Moses it
just says the law and of the prophets
were valid until the time of John the
Baptist now since this person is
targeting The Ten Commandments if the
Ten Commandments cease to be valid the
law at John the Baptist does that
include Thou shalt not
kill does that include Thou shalt not
steal is Thou shalt not kill still valid
the answer is yes and no person in
control of his senses will argue that
thou shalt not commit adultery is still
valid no person will argue that what
people will argue is remember the
Sabbath
day to get rid of that they make an
attempt to get rid of the whole law now
the person says someone else I think I
believe it's someone else I'm not sure
here's what someone writes maybe the
same person I don't know could be listen
to this father as I read this question
be with me God and tell me how to answer
your people whom you love in Jesus name
amen listen carefully there is a
teaching that states that a Sabbath is
God's Mark of ownership on his people
but that is not biblical at all
okay let's go to Ezekiel 20 let's read
verse
12 Ezekiel 20:2 the person said there's
a teaching that the Sabbath is God's
Mark of ownership on his people but that
is not biblical at all
okay Ezekiel
20:12 moreover also I gave them my
sabbaths to be what a sign between me
and them that they might know that I am
the Lord to sanctify them I give them my
Sabbath to be assigned the same thing is
found in Exodus 31:13 in EX in Ezekiel
20:20 so when the person says it is not
biblical this is not strictly
true the sa now the person
says God cannot identify his people with
part of a law and he calls it Moses's
law law whose operation and ability to
bring righteousness out of the
Israelites on which it
was based I guess failed and was
declared null and void and Obsolete and
the person gives Deuteronomy 810 to3 as
the verse or the passage that shows that
the law of God is null void and Obsolete
and he calls the Ten Commandments the
law of Moses all right because the issue
circled around my insistence on the
seventh day Sabbath so we're talking
about the Ten Commandments let's go to
Hebrews 8 let's look at
10-13 we continue with questions and
answers for this this is ezek uh Hebrews
8 from: 10 for this is the Covenant that
I will make with the house of Israel
after those days sayith the Lord I will
put my laws
where where in the heart uhhuh
and write them where in the inward parts
now listen to the words again the person
is giving me this passage as proof that
the laws of God are obsolete what is the
words use obsolete null and declared
null void and obsolete listen to what
the passage says verse 10 for this is
the Covenant the person is referring to
this New Covenant okay which is true
which I will make with the house of
Israel after those days sayi the Lord
here it comes I will do what put my laws
where and do
what yes I'll put my laws in their mind
and write them in their hearts now if
the law is null and void and obsolete
what does God
write he said he predicted that in
Jeremiah
31:33 this is the Covenant I will make
with them after those days said the Lord
I will put my law in the inward parts
and write it in their hearts and I will
be their God and they shall be my people
in the New Covenant you see the old
Covenant let
me we have the old Covenant and the new
here's a mistake many of us make we view
the old Covenant as a matter of
historical time and the New Covenant
also as a matter of historical time the
old Covenant is not so much a matter of
time it is a matter of attitude towards
God or God's law the New Covenant is
also an attitude towards God's law under
the old Covenant the Jews said all that
the Lord have spoken the is life we will
do now this is
self-righteousness all that the Lord has
spoken this is not an Old Testament
problem this is a modern problem there
are people who feel they're righteous
and I can be righteous by doing this and
that and that not realizing Christ has
to make you
righteous and so the old Covenant is not
so much a matter of time it is a matter
of attitude towards God's law and God's
righteousness and God himself when Moses
told the people what God said they said
all that the Lord has spoken we we've
got this covered as we say United States
we got this we'll do it and then the
worshiping an image in chapter 32 the
New Covenant is Lord write your law on
my heart that's the New Covenant that's
how Abraham was saved that's how Adam
was saved there are two approaches to
God trusting God or trusting self
trusting self is the old Covenant
trusting God is the new you see there
aren't two ways to be saved from Adam
until now every saved person has been
saved the same way
through faith in Christ who writes the
law on our
hearts and so when the person says the
New Covenant made the law null and void
and obsolete then tell me what does God
write on the heart and the mind of a
person which is what he's supposed to do
Under the New Covenant Hebrews 8:10 it
also found in Hebrews 10:16 Jeremiah
31:33 what does he write
let me get to
a listen to
this and okay where are we here we are
another question many are struggling
with the question of the Holy Spirit as
the seal and the Sabbath as the seal
which is the seal
both let me ask you
this Jesus said what if you love me come
on that's what he
said if you love me keep my
Commandments if you say to me I love
Jesus how am I supposed to know
that when Jesus condemns just words
these people honth me with their lips
but their hearts are far from me if you
say I love Jesus I ought to see it in
the way you live right or wrong now go
to Galatians 5 let's read from verse 19
and reason through the scriptures it's
25 to8 Galatians 5 verse
19 God bless those of you online praying
for me wherever you are God bless you I
See You by faith you have Galatians 5:
19 Father in heaven continue to tell me
exactly what to do that your word may be
represented a right your truth in Jesus
name I pray amen now the works of the
flesh are manifest which are these what
do you understand by
manifest they're obvious they can be
seen the works of the flesh meaning an
unconverted person The Sinner are
manifest you see them which are these
adultery fornication uncleanness
lasciviousness
idolatry witchcraft hatred variance
emulations wrath Strife seditions
heresies envyings murders drunkenness
rings and such like Paul is saying these
are the evidence that the person is
still in the
flesh you see the flesh is an inward
condition all we just listed are outward
behaviors now verse 22 but the fruit of
the spirit now where do you see the
fruit on the outside of a tree or the
inside the
outside but the fruit of the spirit in
other words the same way I know that
person is flesh by these behaviors I
know this person is a spirit person by
these fruits love joy peace
longsuffering gentleness goodness Faith
meekness Temperance now the Bible goes
on to say at the end of verse 23 of
Galatians 5 against such
there's no law now is there a law
against 19 to 21 adultery fornication
and cleanness listen yes but if the law
was made obsolete by the New Covenant
then there is no adultery there is no
fornication there is no uncleanness
there is no lasciviousness there is no
variance emulations wrath no Strife
seditions heresies no idolatry no
witchcraft no hatred why because the law
has been made D null and void and
obsolete because it is the law that
points out
sin this is evidence you're in the flesh
this is evidence you're in the spirit
now look at the fruits of the spirit a
little more closely verse 22 but the
fruit of the spirit is love joy peace
longsuffering gentleness goodness Faith
meekness Temperance let's look at Faith
now there are two kinds of faith well
really just one but I'll say two one is
Living Faith what's the other
one if one is a living faith what's the
other one a dead Faith all right go to
James chapter
2 James chapter
2 read verse
26 James chapter 2 verse
26 are you there not yet all right it's
21 minutes to 8 you have James 2: 26 the
Bible says for as the body without the
spirit is dead so faith without works is
dead also the faith the spirit gives as
a fruit of the spirit is a faith that
produces works are you with me no spirit
of God will give you a dead
Faith because he's the spirit of Life
Romans 8:1 there's therefore now no
condemnation to them which are in Christ
Jesus who walked not after the flesh but
after the spirit verse Two for the law
of the spirit of life in Christ Jesus
John 6:63 the words that I speak unto
you they are spirit and they are life
the spirit gives life if the spirit
gives faith it is a living faith and a
faith is only alive if it is evidence by
works and so when we have the fruit of
the spirit called faith it is Dem
demonstrated and that demonstration that
works is obedience to the law of God
I'll tell you something else the person
says the spirit who is to seal the
spirit or the of the Sabbath and I'll
get into that a little more go to acts
5:32 acts
532 we're coming to the end of questions
and answers acts chap
5:32 say that Peter and John is and the
disciples
speaking and we are his Witnesses of
these things and so is also the Holy
Ghost whom God hath given to them that
do what obey him now if the law has been
made dull and void to them that obey
what if the New Covenant has made the
law null and void and obsolete Christ
has gone back he died he rose he has
validated the new COV he's in heaven now
one of his disciples filled with the
Holy Ghost says the spirit is given to
those who
obey obey
what the
spirit is a
seal that's
internal If any man hath not the spirit
of Christ he's none of his Romans 8:9 If
any man hath not the spirit of Christ
sees none of his the presence of the
spirit of God in a person identifies
that person as a child of God but that's
internal you don't know who's filled
with the spirit unless by out external
Behavior I don't mean the spirit where
you run around the church and you fall
down and you faint no no no that's a
different
Spirit Sabbath
keeping is an external seal
because it is manifested in your
behavior you don't work you don't do
certain things on a holy day as the
Bible requires Isaiah 583 and4 you you
actually you have a whole day to prepare
and then the holy day comes everything
about you changes and people notice
that's an outward
seal the spirit in you leads you to
exercise that outward seal so we have
internal and we have external in the old
test
there were two seals one was
circumcision there are men sitting
around here you don't know who
circumcised that's internal that's
hidden but there was also the Sabbath as
a sign so there were two the Sabbath
circumcision one was Private one was
public because Faith must have
works are you with me and so if you say
I'm filled with the spirit show
me and you show it by a life of
obedience to God now if the New
Testament has made the law of God null
void and obsolete there is no judgment
why do I say that go to James chapter
2 James is written about 20 to 30 years
after Jesus went back this is the half
brother of Christ the Book of James was
written between 20 and 30 years after
Christ went back to heaven after he
validated the New Covenant here's what
the brother of Jesus says James 2:8 I'll
pray father I'm coming to the end but
continue to speak through me please in
Jesus name I pray amen if ye fulfill the
Royal law according to the scripture
Thou shalt love thy neighbor as thyself
you do well but if you have respect to
persons you commit sin and are convinced
of the law of as transgressors for
whosoever shall keep the whole law and
yet offend in one point he's guilty of
all now James identifies
for he that said verse 11 do not commit
adultery said also do not kill from
where is James
quoting The Ten
Commandments the brother of Jesus is the
one speaking this is 30 years after
Jesus went back and he's saying you if
you break one you've broken all then he
quotes two to let us know what he's
referring to he's referring to the tent
clearly then in the days of James James
did not believe that the New Covenant
rendered God's law null Obsolete and
void let us go to Romans the mighty
mighty Apostle the most powerful teacher
after Jesus Christ the Apostle
Paul Romans 13 reading from verse 8 our
subject question and
answers owe no man anything but to love
one another for he that loveth another
hasth fulfilled the law for this Thou
shalt not commit adultery Thou shalt not
kill Thou shalt not steal honor thy
father thy mother Paul quotes from The
Ten Commandments and he ends that verse
and if there be any other commandment it
is briefly comprehended in this saying
namely Thou shalt love thy neighbor as
thyself which is a summary statement of
the last six Commandments Thou shalt
love the Lord thy God a summary
statement of the first four Paul clearly
did not believe that the New Covenant
cancelled made null and obsolete the law
of God James didn't believe
it and I said you cancel the
Commandments you cancel the Judgment
let's go back to James chapter 2 and
we'll finish off tonight's questions and
answers James
2 read verse
12 after saying in verse 11 he that said
do not do not commit adultery said also
do not kill now if thou commit no
adultery
yet if thou kill Thou Art become a
transgressor of the law listen to a
warning in verse 12 James says so speaky
and so do as
what come on loudly so speaky and so do
as
what they they shall be what judged by
what the law he calls it the Royal law
in verse 8 he calls it the the law of
Liberty in verse 8 he called the law of
Liberty in verse uh 12 the Royal law in
verse 8 The Ten
Commandments James says live your
life as if you realize that one day
you'll be judged by that standard in
God's law now if the New Covenant has
made God's law and I keep using these
words null Obsolete and void where's the
Judgment listen to the wisest man who
ever lived Ecclesiastes 12113 and 14 go
there with me quickly then we pray we're
closing off questions and answers
Ecclesiastes 1213 and
14 and keep
praying I don't want the devil to put
the wrong word in my mouth in the last
five minutes and ruin
everything let us hear the conclusion of
the whole matter fear God and keep his
Commandments read the next few words for
this is the whole duty of man for God
shall bring every work into judgment
with every secret thing whether it be
good or bad or evil the Ten Commandments
of God which represent the whole duty of
man will be the standard by which men
and women are judged into judgment if
you say the New Covenant has made God's
law null void and obsolete then you tell
me how will God conducted judgment with
no
standard by listening for
friends the law of Moses does not refer
to the Ten
Commandments it refers to the first five
books of the
Bible sometimes it says Called Moses as
in Luke 2427 sometimes the law of Moses
Luke
24:44 we found out from 1 Corinthians
9:9 that the law of Moses said Thou
shalt not muscle the ox that treadeth
out the corn we found out that is not in
the ten commandments so the law of Moses
could not refer to the Ten Commandments
we found out that uh in John 8:5 now
Moses in the law commanded that such
should be stoned the penalty for
adultery we found out the Lord does not
give the penalty for adultery The Ten
Commandments it is found in Deuteronomy
2122 to 24 22 21- 24 and Leviticus 20:1
the law of Moses is a reference to the
first five
books we must study the Bible in context
and the very first verse
uh which was brought to me Luke 16:16
the law and the prophets were until
Moses refers to Simply the writings of
the Old Testament which were the primary
source of information until John came
and presented it in a way that seemed
different to them because when Jesus
preached the people said we've never
heard this but it was in the Old
Testament all along but they said we've
never heard it because he presented it
differently and if you leave Luke 16:16
we're presumably the the law has been
ended verse 17 says and it is easier for
heaven and earth to pass than one title
of the law to fail Christ cannot say in
verse 16 the law ended with John and
then say in verse 17 Heaven and Earth
will pass away first before the smallest
portion of that law can
end we must reason through the
scriptures we must ask the spirit of God
to guide us and let me tell you why the
Lord is such a problem Romans 8:7 you
don't need to go this listen because the
carnal mind is enmity against God for it
is not subject to the law of God neither
indeed we are born with a fundamental
opposition to God's law let me say it
again we are born with a genetic
opposition to God's
law that's why you have to be converted
not improved converted because we that's
why God's very first promise Genesis
3:15 and I will put enmity between thee
and the woman because no sinner will put
enmity in his or her heart for the law
of God God has to put
enmity in that person's heart for sin we
are born that way and so we find
ourselves naturally opposing the law of
God but the law of God is a law of love
the Angels keep it Psalm
103:20 bless the Lord ye his angels that
excel in strength that do his
Commandments heartening under the voice
of the Lord if the New Covenant canel
the law what do the Angels
keep my listening friends study the
Bible very carefully go to it to find
out what he wants to say to you don't go
to it to find evidence to establish what
you believe go and let the word speak to
you the law of God the Ten Commandments
of God are still enforc and will remain
forever because in Isaiah 66:23 the
Bible says it shall come to pass
referring to the new world that from one
new moon to another and from one Sabbath
to another shall All Flesh come to
worship before me this is a reference to
the new world ask God to put into your
heart and mind a love for that standard
of righteousness because Jesus said who
initiated the New Covenant he who
validated it I should say he said if he
keep my Commandments you shall abide in
my love even as I have kept my father's
Commandments and ab in his love and when
Jesus Christ is in the heart the number
one impulse is obedience how many of you
will say father give me a love for your
law of Love Can I see your hand pray
with me father in the name of Jesus we
thank you for this session I've done my
best as a human being a weak effort
father but I pray that your spirit will
go behind me de God and magnify what I
try to say make it clear because you
love everyone listening to God and
you're not willing that any should
perish
give us a love for right doing let us
say like David oh how love I thy La it
is my meditation all the day hear this
humble prayer father bring us back
tomorrow night I pray in Jesus name let
God's people say amen and amen good
night everyone drive safely come back
tomorrow we have Thursday Friday and we
end on Sabbath 3 days left may the Lord
be with you and your family as you sleep
tonight
[Music]
the